how do you write with empathy
oh that's great um how to write about
empathy uh
i think um
and that's kind of important because you
you always want to try having
different voices right for each
character each character can't
sound the same so whether this person is
a killer or this person is
a police officer this person is a
teacher
you gotta try to feel
what their life is and their challenges
and their hopes and dreams
uh everyone has those there you know
there's certain
human emotions that we all have and i
try to kind of
place that um and feel that
so if i could feel that then i think i
could be
empathetic to that situa situation
i might not necessarily always get it
correct um
but or executed executed well but
i i try to do that i try to um
feel but sometimes i could get me in
trouble being too empathetic because you
become like a devil's advocate
all the time tell my wife that i was
like can you just agree
agree you know i was like all right but
well this person's but maybe you know
maybe the customer service person is you
know had ten calls before they were
they're
you know difficult he's like well mine
was difficult i was like well i was just
trying to feel what they
what they were going through you know so
it could help but it also could be
um you know a nuisance
with all roads to perrla the with the
main characters
how did you want to have the audience
feel some empathy toward them or was
that not a goal
um you know
i was thinking about that of like
i hope i hope for the audience i hope
what people could get out of or see or
feel
is like we're
sometimes we're born in certain
situations that we're
we're given and um
and sometimes we try the best we can
and sometimes that's not enough and i
hope
people could understand that you know
it's it's
whether it's effort and with the main
characters
it was a simple goal of just um
trying to survive but isn't that what
we're all
trying to do you know but everyone has
their own ways and it's it's it's one of
those things of like
if you question behavior especially even
like domestic violence and things and
people always go
oh why didn't they leave i was like
don't understand what the word
coercion means or doesn't understand
what
the situation is it's not as simple as
that it's there's
their complex layer layer to things so
with these characters
and on our main uh lead
um played by alex mcnichol brandon
he's a high school wrestler and i was a
high school wrestler
so when you are starving starving for
love
starving for food starving for tension
you become very primal you know you
start this
there's a different type of clarity
which is
you know basic need we need basic need
and and you know that's why that
definition of love lust and loss
like a slap to a face could be someone's
definition of love
but we some people think that's
brutality
violence but if you're born in that
situation if that's all you've known
and when a hug is
not there you act differently so so um
yeah that's why i was exploring with
that with with these characters and
and i hope the audience could kind of
like um go along with it
do you mind if the audience judges your
characters you know some people might be
fearful
especially if they weren't born into
certain situations and they know
comfort or not just affluence but
comfort
and structure but not everybody had that
and i think a lot of people that don't
did that they came from that they're
very fearful of anything that looks to
oh no no that's dirty i don't want to
touch that kind of thing
yeah yeah i i think you know i think
that's
that's a that's a great thing about
creating something it it
and it's total opposite of me i always
you know i was so diplomatic going up i
always want didn't want to get on
anyone's
bad side and all i was this i was always
writing a fence it didn't have like
super strong opinions but with this with
the story
um i think everyone's entitled to to to
it and
it and if it upsets them it's in if they
don't think that's portrayed right or
i'm not being um really empathetic but
but
but being um something other than that
uh i think people have a right for that
then and i like that because that's the
beginning of this course
so so but you know
you you hope people could understand
that but i
i think during this entire process even
trying to get the film off the
ground trying to have a sustainable
career in the arts field
i've learned how to kind of let let go
you know and that's a
very um hard thing hard thing
to you know to have you work be
criticized all the time but
but um i just you know i'm very proud of
it
and i think it's kind of like it's off
in its own
it's it's if i were to have children i
i guess that would be like do you just
hope
someone you know hugs it once in a while
that's about it
so it's okay with you to write about
characters that may not be loved by
everyone and maybe disliked by certain
people
not necessarily the story but who the
characters are is that okay with you
even though
you know about yourself you like to be
diplomatic and think of others first
yeah i think so i think that's what you
know uh that's the fun part of creating
because
those are characters those are um
they say you know real life is stranger
than fiction
there's more characters out there that's
looney tunes and awful but
it's life and you know i i love
i love those characters come alive and
and and and and seeing it from through
their eyes and
and what they have to go through yeah
what if you're writing a character and
you don't feel empathy toward that
character
that's a no if i don't if i don't feel
empathy to that character
um
that's a hard one it makes me think of
that sean penn movie uh
but helen uh saint paul uh dead man
walking
right so
i don't know i think i even through
let's say let's say it's like charles
manson or
or other things i would convince myself
at
birth there was a sense of innocence
somewhere there and this person through
society through
upbringing through other things
fell into um the wrong
world and became a monster
um so i would go all the way i would
have to
go out and investigate that um
and see you know so but it'll be a
little bit
more difficult i would say yeah if i
didn't have any empathy towards them
you